When you buy a tube of paint,
what's in that tube primarily
is pigment and binder.
Pigment is the color matter.
It's the stuff that
provides paint with color.
Now, these can be finely
ground up minerals.
They can be natural products as well.
The binder is essentially the glue,
the adhesive of the paint,
the stuff that sticks all those
little flecks of color together.
The binder of oil paint is linseed oil,
literally the oil from flax seeds.
So essentially we have the pigment,
the color matter going into the binder
which holds it all together
and then this is mostly what paint is.
Using a glass muller, I'm
ensuring that the pigment evenly
is dispersed into that oil,
as I'm really making sure
this paint has a uniform consistency.
If you buy a tube of paint today,
this stuff is done by
huge industrial processes
rather than the old-fashioned handmade
way that I'm demonstrating here.
Now the more oil that
is added to the paint,
the more translucent that paint becomes.
Because this oil is barely colored,
it has a slight yellow cast to it,
the more of that we add, the further
we push apart those
little flecks of color,
those little bits of pigment.
If they're spread apart
into what's called the glaze
with a lot of linseed oil, then we can see
through that paint.
I'm making it translucent.